welcome back to CBS this morning
protests in Minneapolis over the death
of George Floyd took a shocking turn
last night when demonstrators broke into
a police station and set it on fire
anger over Floyd's death is also
building in other cities all across
America there were protests last night
in places like Denver in Phoenix in New
York City Columbus Ohio Los Angeles and
Chicago Gale and hanging over all of
this for context as a simple fact that
young black men and boys have had a 1 in
1,000 chance of dying at the hands of
police in recent years according to the
strongest available research on the
subject that certainly puts into context
the anger that you see on the street
here that is more than 2 times the rate
that white men and boys die at the hands
of police and if there's a way to
understand what's behind all this
there's a long history and then there's
also that short and violent history that
I just mentioned mm-hmm and that is what
the protesters exactly what the
protesters want you to know Tony there
is a lot of pain and anger in
Minneapolis this morning and based on
what Tony just said you see there's a
lot of pain and anger in this country
the NBA's Minnesota Timberwolves
released a statement sending condolences
to his family it says in part quote we
will work tirelessly to use our voices
to influence change encourage healing
and promote thoughtful action as we move
forward
Kevin Burleson is an assistant coach
with the team he also went to the
University of Minnesota and he is a
brother of CBS Sports Nate Burleson good
morning to you Kevin we're glad to see
you I'm sorry though it's under these
circumstances I know you know this city
very well I'm curious about what you saw
and what you heard last night how close
you live to the area well yeah I'm right
downtown so you know I'm hearing the
sirens and the protestors all night and
it's tough because you know it's one of
things where obviously you don't want
the vandalism the damage and you know
some of the violence but you could feel
the frustration the sad
in the city so it's kind of is this hard
to you know tell people how to mourn and
I'm obviously I don't condone the
violence and everything like that but
this is you know you could feel their
pain for the city's pain you said it's
hard to tell people how to mourn are you
concerned that the looting will
overshadow the what this is really all
about the death the very untimely
unfortunate death of George George Floyd
are you concerned that that message will
be lost in all of this um yes somewhat
and because this is not what it's about
I think if you talk to most of the
protesters even if some of them that are
doing some of the damage they're saying
things like you know we don't want to do
this and this is not what we're about
but we don't know what else to do will
frustrate it we feel like we don't have
a voice so I think it's calm almost like
they have their hands in the air and and
just looking for answers yeah it's hard
though Kevin when you look at the images
and people are burning down their own
communities or they're taking TVs from
Target you think what does that got to
do with the death of George Floyd but
again I think people have to look at the
history of what has happened in
Minneapolis yeah I mean it's one of the
things where you know I was talk to my
brother and one of the things we talked
about it this is not shocking because
this is something happens all the time
in many cities and in Minneapolis
Fernando Castillo just about four years
ago you know I think people thought you
know they're gonna be some type of
police reform and some hope and then
when the officer got off on that and
there's a lot of pent-up anger Kevin
you're talking lando case where he was
shot in the car with his seatbelt on
were you announced I have a gun and a
permit to have a gun you're talking
about that case yes yeah they're talking
about that case and I actually wasn't
here for that but I've never seen that
and I mean obviously tears came to my
eyes because that can been me my brother
my cousin anybody and I think the city
you know holds that and like I said
there's things that happen all the time
that's not filmed
that stays in that community and that
trauma just stays in inside of them so
when things like this happened a
senseless death and almost in slow
motion in front of you I mean that
pent-up anger has to come out so I don't
condone Al I think most of the
protesters don't condone a lot of
stuff's going on but they feel like they
have no choice Kevin it's it's Anthony
Mason I know you all had a team meeting
about this what did you say in that
meeting well I mean honestly the beiongs
for myself I was a little emotional so
actually it was more observer t'v and
listen but we had a lot of leaders on in
that meeting or our GM our head coach
and a lot of other staff members talks
and uh it was a more is more about you
know you know how some of the players
and the staff and co-founders were
talking about how are we gonna help heal
the community and how we can support
Georgians family and you know whatever
we can do so it was a good meeting and I
think a lot of players are really want
to be involved and they want to be
evolving the right way and you know
you'll see something soon I'm pretty
sure all right I thought it was
interesting Kevin that you said you
can't tell people how to mourn in
circumstances like this what's your
bottom line on what you hope we will all
take away from this well you know just
looking at the city and how people are
uniting I mean it might not be exactly
the right way for you know a viewer and
saying hey the looting they're doing
this and doing that but you'll see white
black Asian there's all different types
of races downtown supporting and
everybody's not looting and everybody's
not vandalizing but they're supporting
because they want to see justice and and
it's in my opinion just be realistic
--less that we're not seeing
just as swiftly so I just want you know
everybody take away that we are uniting
down here there's people on the front
lines that are really doing great things
and there's activists out here that's
been doing it for a long time and really
pushing
you know for police performing all that
so we're going to justice all right
Kevin Burleson thank you